When we are talking, when we were talking to the nurse at the oncologist office, we asked about cancer feeding off of sugar, she said she thought that was a myth because they've had out of control diabetics survive cancer.
She said that if it were true that cancer feeds on sugar, all diabetics would have cancer and no more diabetics would ever survive it.
I know there's a flaw with this reason, but don't know what it is. I was curious to know how to respond to that.
Well, first of all, I would not take a dogmatic position that all cancer feeds off of sugar directly.
But to say that cancer doesn't feed off of sugar is literally to say that you don't understand basic human physiology.
That you learned, maybe you forgot, that you learned this in seventh grade biology.
So you learned about glycolysis in seventh grade biology. And glycolysis takes place in all cells.
And this is how you make energy, never ATP.
So glycolysis takes a glucose molecule, breaks it down, and ultimately in the fetal cleanse I made that goes into the crem cycle.
Ever those terms from seventh grade biology, every cell makes energy that way. Sodium, cancer cells, cancer cells actually can feed off of what's called an anaerobic cycle.
So ultimately glucose goes through glycolysis and makes lactic acid at the end.
Well, actually it converts to lactic acid and cancer cells in an anaerobic environment can feed off of lactic acid.
It's really an efficient way to make energy because you make a lot more energy when it converts to acetyl coenzyme and goes into the crem cycle and you really kick out the ATP.
But cancer cells can be damaged, especially if they have HIV, one defects in their genes that are converting the end plate of glycolysis into acetyl coenzyme.
I think it's too technical, but to say that cancer doesn't feed off of sugar is really saying that you don't understand basic physiology.
Every cell will feed off of sugar.
But if you want to get even more technical cancer can cancer cells can feed off of other things as well.
They can feed off of proteins, typically amino acids, cyanide, glutamine, lysine even, cancer can be gobbling up, iron as a fuel source.
So cancer is trying to make energy in order to continue its replication with cancer cells are damaged.
So does everybody that has cancer have to go on a ketogenic diet? No, because not all cancers are feeding mainly directly off of glucose.
But all cells you do use glucose for a female. So cancer cells certainly use glucose as a fuel too.
To say that out of control diabetics, when it's survived cancer, this also tells you that this nurse is not understanding what diabetes is.
So diabetes isn't that you have access glucose in the bloodstream because just because you eat way too much glucose.
Diabetes is that you have access glucose in the bloodstream because it can't get into the cells.
So the disease of diabetes in the adult onset type two diabetes is that cancer, the glucose can't get in the cell because the receptors on the outside of the cell membrane are damaged.
So all your cells are reproducing damaged receptors on the outside of cell membrane so the glucose can't get inside the cell. Therefore, there's excess glucose circulating in the bloodstream.
That's what diabetes is.
It can begin because a person had a poor diet and ate way too much sugar, but a person could actually have a good diet not eat very much sugar at all and end up with it with a type two diabetes.
And excess blood sugar type one diabetes has to do with an insulin deficiency because of an autoimmune disease in the pancreas, what's damaging the production of insulin, therefore they can't get the glucose inside the cell.
So in order for glucose to get inside the cell and you need insulin made by the pancreas and you need healthy cell receptors or glucose, whatever you have an issue with one of those you could end up with access blood glucose.
So to say that out of control diabetics would never survive cancer because cancer is fed off of glucose, you're not understanding either you're both not understanding physiology and you're not understanding that what diabetes is so diabetes is that the glucose can't get inside the cells.
So it really shows, I don't want to be read, but it really shows this person's complete ignorance.